[Music]
hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know I'm Pastor
Steven bore president of Secrets
unsealed and sutv thank you so much for
joining us today I just want to mention
uh that um I have with me two
distinguished individuals who help us
here with this program uh to my right I
have uh Danielle Miranda uh who is
associate pastor of Fresno Central 7th
Day Adventist Church uh he comes here
and he helps us a lot with sermons and
with I'd like to know and other
programming thank you for joining us
Pastor Miranda thank you thank you
Pastor bour for allowing me to be in
this panel is AE is a privilege and a
pleasure for me praise the Lord and I
have to my left side I have David
Salazar uh he coordinates all of our
Spanish work uh all of our Spanish
programs and our Spanish Personnel here
at the ministry and it's always a
pleasure to have him on this program I
always appreciate the fact that he
always has a smile on his face I've
never seen him with a long face thank
you for joining us praise the Lord
Pastor is a blessing for me to be with
you and with Danielle in this planel and
um by the way we also have programming
done by his wife and his girls so thank
you so much for joining us for the
program today uh if you want to send us
a question you'll see it on the screen
uh TVM tv.org
TVM tv.org uh send us your questions we
have many of them uh if they're not
answered in the the immediate future be
sure that we place them in order and
they will receive an answer in the
course of time uh we have several
interesting questions today and uh
before we actually answer those
questions we need to plead for divine
guidance and so I want to ask Pastor mid
if he would please pray and ask for the
Lord to be with us absolutely let us
pray our gracious heavenly father as we
get ready to answer these questions we
do not dare to open your word without
your guidance amen so we pray that
through your Holy Spirit you may
Enlighten our minds so that we may
answer this questions only based on what
you have revealed to us in your word we
pray all these things in the name of
Jesus amen amen amen you know folks uh
we appreciate this program tremendously
and also the viewers everywhere I go
people say I'd love I love the program
I'd like to know and one of the reasons
why we love love this program is because
it makes us do research right there are
many questions that I've never heard
before I've never asked and it leads me
to the Bible to do research amen and
find answers to the questions and that's
what we intend to do here at Secrets
unsealed in this particular program we
have a very interesting question here uh
this comes um this is actually from
2023 uh from
R and uh it reads like this hello
pastors many thanks for your program I'd
like to know my question is from
Galatians 5 verse
23 and he only quotes um verse 23 uh but
you have context the fruit of the spirit
it says meekness Temperance Temperance
against such there is no law and then
here's the question since there is no
law against the Fruit of the Spirit
how do we establish one that one has to
keep the Sabbath many things in advance
so if there's no law against the fruit
of the spirit why do we have to keep the
Sabbath basically that's the question MH
so how do we answer that question well
the first thing I would say is that we
do not build a Doctrine based on one
Isola text and number two there is clear
evidence in the Bible that first of all
the law is still binding and that we're
supposed to keep all the Commandments of
God so here the issue is with that
expression against such there is no law
if we look at the context for example in
verse 16 of the same chapter in
Galatians chapter 5 it says I say then
walk in the spirit and you shall not
fulfill the lust of the flesh so here we
are told that we are supposed to walk in
the spirit and the way we walk in the
spirit is or the evidence that we're
walking in the spirit is the fruits of
the spirit but notice now Verse 18 but
if you are led by the spirit you are not
under the
law so this is very this is the same
thing as against such there is no law
what does it mean that if we are led by
the spirit we are not under the law well
that expression is used several times in
the New Testament by the same author
Paul one of them which for me is the
clearest one is in Romans 3: 19 Romans
3:
19 what does it mean to be under the
law verse 19 says after the description
of the character of those who are wicked
and have transgress the law of God it
says now we know that whatever the law
says it says to those who are under the
law that every mouth may be stopped and
that all the world may come guilty
before God so what is it that the Lord
says you read the previous verses there
is no righteous not not one and there it
describes some of the sins uh deceit
there is deceit in their tongues their
mouth is full of cursing verse 14 verse
15 their feet are Swift to shed blood so
whatever the law says it says to those
who are under under the law so those who
are under the law are those who are
walking in
Disobedience to the law but when we are
led by the spirit to to keep the law MH
then against such there is no law in
other words the
law the law does not condemn us because
now we are walking by the
spirit and there is and before I I we we
pass it on to to one of you I have one
more point a good illustration of this
is Romans 7: 1-6 where there is an
allegory of a woman woman that is
married to a husband and then if the
husband dies she's free to marry another
husband okay she's free to remarry in
other words but if she remarries and I'm
just paraphrasing it you can read it on
your own uh this Romans 7: 1-6 but let
me read verse four therefore my brethren
actually verse three so then if while
her husband leaves she marries another
man she will be called an adulteress but
if her husband dies she is free from
that law so that she's not adulterous
though she has married another man so
basically here the first man is the the
the the old man in the context the new
man is Christ what the Apostle Paul is
saying here is that if you try to marry
Christ while the old man hasn't died
completely you're committing spiritual
adultery and you cannot please two
masters what bringing this to Galatians
chapter
5 when we have died to the flesh the
fruits of the flesh are mentioned before
for the fruits of the spirit then we can
freely walk in newness of life
manifesting in our lives the fruits of
the spirit in other words we are free in
what sense we are free in the sense that
now we can keep the law of God through
the spirit and that's why James calls it
the law of Liberty amen yeah and you
know the a very important point is I'm
going to let you amplify this but a very
import important point is that um there
are nine other
commandments so if you have the fruit of
the spirit why do you need to not commit
adultery if you have the fruit of the
spirit why why uh do you not steal
correct uh why do you honor your parents
there's no
dichotomy between the Fruit of the
Spirit and the observance of God's law
uh sometimes we create a dichotomy
between the law and the spirit but
really there's no reason to do that
because because the Holy Spirit was the
one who wrote the
law uh and so how can you say that the
fruit of the spirit is in
conflict with the law of God if the holy
spirit is the one who wrote the law with
his finger on tables of his Stone and
somebody might say well how do you know
that the Holy Spirit wrote the law uh on
tables of stone well Matthew 12:28 Jesus
says if I cast out demons by
the by the uh Spirit by the spirit of
God then uh the kingdom has come upon
you but in Luke 11:20 it says uh if I
cast out Spirits by the Finger of God
then uh you know the verse continues and
so uh basically the Holy Spirit wrote
the law so why would the fruit of the
spirit be in conflict with the law it do
makes sense and then to point
specifically to the Sabbath of all the
Commandments as they want not to keep it
also is contradictory um but to add to
what Pastor Danielle was mentioning you
know in the same chapter of Galatians 5
verse 14 it sort of gives us this
definition it says for all the law is
fulfilled in one word even in this Thou
shalt love thy neighbor as thyself so
Paul is explaining that the fruit of the
spirit which is truly the love of God
flowing in your life in actions in
meekness in patience in uh kindness in
Temperance against those things the law
is fulfilled there's this why there's no
law against it the law is actually
fulfilled in that action you're actually
fulfilling the law and this is what he's
saying in regards to why the law or
there was no law against that or is
contrary to the fruits of the spirit
because it's actually fulfillment of the
law and if we connect that to John 1
John uh two
verse uh four uh verse three 1 John 2:3
it says and hereby we do know that we
know him if we keep his Commandments he
that said I know him and keepeth not his
Commandments is a liar and the truth is
not in him right but whosoever keepeth
his word in him verely the love of God
per is perfected hereby we know that we
are in him that he and he said that he
abided in him ought himself also to walk
even as he walked so truly when you have
the love of God uh flowing in your life
you're going to fulfill the Commandments
you're going to actually fulfill the law
there's not going to be a law against
you but actually flowing through your
life in the actions of doing the
Commandments of God and you're not going
to have a problem with anything of the
law all Ten Commandments you can delight
yourself into do and and please yourself
in doing them as they are actually the
Fulfillment of the law of God you know
it's interesting that the first fruit
that is made
Y is love y and once a theologian came
to
Jesus and asked Jesus what was the great
commandment in the
law and Jesus says you're you're the
scholar you tell
me and then he says I'm summarizing love
for God and love for your neighbor and
then Jesus says well do this and you
will live so they're speaking about the
Ten
Commandments yeah
love the list in Galatians 5 begins with
love right so is there a contradiction
between love and the fruit of the spirit
and love and keeping the Commandments no
absolutely absolutely not Harmony and
and it says the fruit of the spirit is
singular MH so love as the foundation
from love the other fruits spring forth
yeah amen and the law is a law of Love
absolutely so we cannot separate both of
them yeah yeah yeah if you love God
you're going to keep the first four
Commandments that's right and if you
love your neighbor you're going to keep
the last six amen I mean it's that
simple and so there's no conflict
summarizing there's no conflict between
the fruit of the spirit the first on the
list is love and loving God and loving
your neighbor um this argument I've
heard before that all we need is the
fruit of the spirit you know we don't
need to keep the Commandments all we
need to make sure we have the Holy
Spirit I remember I had a couple uh that
came to one of my Evangelistic meetings
when I was ministerial director in the
Texico conference and they came to all
of the meetings the the last meeting
that they came to was the one on the
Sabbath and immediately after the
Sabbath presentation I always go and
visit people uh to see how they felt
about the presentation so I visited
their home an elderly couple and I said
did you understand the the sermon on the
Sabbath they say yes yes very very good
they said um did you understand that the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
and that we're supposed to keep it oh
absolutely yes so I said uh then uh
you're planning on keeping it and the
lady looks at me and she says we don't
have to keep it we have the Holy Spirit
they were charismatic and this is a true
story and so they put a dichotomy
between Having the Holy Spirit you know
and raising your hands and shouting
tongues that even God can't understand
and everything and they replace the
observance of God commandment with the
supposed presence of the Holy Spirit no
contradiction and it's so sad Pastor you
know that they always single out the
Sabbath being the center of the law you
know being you know the one that really
points us to the Creator it's they have
a problem they don't have a problem with
the rest of nine you know right honoring
their parents not lying not cheating all
these things but when it comes to the
Sabbath is the only one they have a
problem with it's is the enemy really
trying to mislead them but but then they
use regarding the other nine
Commandments they say well we're not
under law we're under grace so even if
we commit adultery and steel and
everything we're under grace so it
doesn't make any difference so it's
amazing the way Satan has wanted to
discard the law and that was the first
thing that he attacked in heaven yeah
was God's law because it's a God love
love he attacked loveh because the law
is all about love for God and for our
neighbor okay let's go to our next
question uh this one is very interesting
doesn't say where it's coming from um it
actually is two questions what is the
difference between a pastor and a church
Elder is their ordination different can
we clarify this a pastor as an elder can
is a pastor an elder in other words so
what can we say about the the difference
if there is any between an elder a
pastor who wants to measure in first
well biblically speaking Pastor you know
there is um the role of the pastor is
the same role as an elder or a or a
bishop if you if you you know using the
language that the Bible uses uh is the
same role in other words the elders the
local Elders
were elected and they were appointed and
they were ordained to serve the local
community to serve their Church to um
oversee it not to administ you know to
be administrators as as dictators or
managers you know in the sense of the
word but to serve to really Minister for
the needs to be able to uh see where
perhaps a family or a member was needing
dedication time support friendship Etc
so that's why the role of the minister
or the Elder in the local church is
pretty much the same as a pastor now um
in the difference with a pastor is that
a pastor has to oversee more than one
specific Church you know usually is a
district or several churches and in some
areas even larger you know several
cities uh that's probably the only
difference as far as biblically what the
role of One Versus the other would be uh
but um obviously today we seem to think
of a pastor as a much higher position
and a Elder as a lesser position but
really before the Lord they are the same
bially speaking uh you know I've uh
participated in many ordination
services and um there really uh is not a
passage in the Bible that has ever been
read at an
ordination that deals with the
ordination of a
pastor it's always a passage that has to
do with the role of the overseer which
is the word Bishop right or the role of
the Elder in other words the passage is
dealing with elders and with overseers
but they're read for the ordination of a
pastor which shows that there really is
no difference between the ordination of
a pastor and the ordination of an elder
except that a
pastor uh has a credential to serve the
World Church whereas the local Elder
serves in the local church where the
Elder belongs to correct yeah yeah in
fact what you were saying in 1 Timothy
chap 3 verse one this is a faithful
saying if a man desires the position of
a bishop he desires a good thing and
some versions translated as Elder and
Bishop is the word episcopus in the
Greek canover here and that word applies
both to pastors and
Elders yeah um and presos
presos is the is the word Elder and
basically it me means someone uh of age
literally so it has to be somebody who's
wise somebody who has experience
somebody who has um has less tread on
their tires if I can say than most
people that have been through different
experiences in in the local church uh so
uh the bottom line is uh summarizing the
answer uh there is no distinction
between the ordination of an elder and
the ordination of a pastor except that
the Elder ser serves the local church
whereas the pastor is authorized to
serve on a global level correct all
right the second question actually we
have three here the second question is I
think this one will be very easy to
answer what is the sea of glass of the
Book of Revelation CH 4 and verse 6 and
Revelation
15:2 and will there be a baptism in the
sea of
glass so uh how do we answer actually
there's a couple of questions here but
uh dealing with the same
subject what is the sea of glass let's
start in my in my evaluation of of
this we cannot truly describe how Heaven
is because we have never been there and
we rely only on inspiration what the
Bible tells us sometimes the prophets
from their perspective this is what they
were seeing and they're trying to find
the best language possible to describe
things so so in Revelation 4: 6 this is
one of the verses quoted here before the
throne there was a sea of glass like
Crystal and then Revelation 15 and verse
two the other verse quoted here in the
question and I saw something like I saw
something like a sea of glass mingled
with fire which is from the presence of
God and those who have the victory over
the Beast over his image over the mark
and over the number of his name standing
on the sea of glass having harbs of gold
so this sea of glass
is a material or something that
reflects the glory of God and when the
glory of God reflects on it it looks
like fire MH now I am not very certain
what kind of material that is um
Revelation also tells that this is the
the streets were of gold so definitely
is a very expensive material probably
also the idea of glass is that that
transparency you know um another thing
that he probably saw and he could
probably describe as best as he could as
something that's transparent that we
could see through infinitely in a way
you know it's not like the water today
that's murky or it's like you know if
you go to see a river and it's
especially the River Jordan was very
murky very you know full of mud speaking
of the beautiful the clear the clarity
the the brightness the fact that it was
looked like a like a glass like mirror
perhaps so it's something in those words
that you mentioned Pastor that you know
what he could see that John Revelator
was just able to put it in writing what
he was able to see but besides that
there's really no other you know Clarity
of exactly how it is is things that we
cannot even imagine as as the Bible says
you know I think that um it's helpful to
realize that the Book of Revelation
tells us that there's a river of Water
of Life that flows from the Throne of
God MH and most most likely because the
sea of glass is Before the Throne that
the water from the River of Life goes
into the sea of glass now it's not made
of glass MH it's just so transparent and
so Serene and so calm and so clear yeah
that it looks like glass right you know
I've been there's this place up in uh
Grand Tian National Park uh where I love
to go when I go up to that area of
Wyoming um it's a certain place where
there is a lake with beautiful trees in
the background and a mountain with u
with snow on it in the background and
early in the morning the sea or that
that lake is so calm there's no wind no
Ripple that you see a perfect reflection
of the background into the water and
it's and and I took a picture of it hard
it's hard to tell what is the original
and what's the copy in the picture
because you know you can turn it both
ways and it looks like it's uh like it's
you
know the reality EXA wow uh great
controversy 648 Ellen White wrote upon
the crystal sea Before the Throne the
sea of glass as it were mingled with
fire and then she explains why so
resplendant is it with the glory of God
are gathered the company that have
gotten the victory over over the Beast
over his image over his Mark and over
the number of his name so the reason why
it looks like it's mingled with fire is
because the glory of God is reflected in
it and uh it is I believe it's real
water but it's very very calm so it
looks like glass it looks like Crystal
doesn't look like the Jordan River amen
amen and of course there won't be
baptisms because there will be no more
sin of course over there amen well thank
you for joining us our time is up please
send us your questions sum tv.org God
bless you and we hope to see you next
time on this program God
[Music]
bless